hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Alan Saki and today we're
sitting down with Zoltan he's fun how
are you doing sir
thanks for coming on so appreciate it
I'm excited yes we have Zoltan
simulation we're gonna be talking about
transhumanism we're talk about his book
and we're gonna talk about the
California Governor race in 2018 this is
gonna be a good trek we have what does
it mean to even merge with machines and
you've been in this how long have you
been in transhumanism excited about it
well you know I was always interested in
reading science fiction growing up and I
thought I want to be a scientist but I
you know I think in college I read a an
article on cryonics and as soon as I
realized that there was a movement that
was dedicated to overcoming death with
science which is really what the grants
humanism is about I just said this is it
this is what I want to do with my life
and I ever since then I'm sort of been
connected to it working in it a part of
it you know growing in it and those
kinds of things but really just I think
some people that get into transhumanism
and want to overcome death with science
it's a clique in their brain and they're
like wow this is what I want to do with
my life and so that was 10 years taught
how long ago so I'm 44 almost 45 I guess
that's looking at around 20 to 21 years
warriors ago now Wow
so that moment that's great that you
talk about that moment because we love
talking about these mind-expanding
moments of life and you know you and
Albert gray and so many people are now
trying to help people understand that
it's it's a moment that kind of clicks
not necessarily to say that you're gonna
live forever and it's really important
for you to live forever but more so that
how about the choice to be in good
health as long as possible as long as
you want yeah no I mean in obviously
that you know a lot of people speak
about immortality like let's live
forever but really what we're trying to
do is just say
dying sucks we want some control over
this phenomenon in life and maybe even
to overcome it entirely but you know
there's an anecdote and the kind of a
personal story about how I really like
joined the trans Hemus movement I
suppose officially which is you know I'd
been working for National Geographic for
a number of years as a journalist and
I've been covering a lot of conflict
zones but I had a very scary incident
happened to me in Vietnam when I was
doing a story on people digging up bombs
where I had almost stepped on a landmine
and my guide sort of pushed me out of
the way and it was a revelation to me
because I'd been doing so many dangerous
things as a journalist yeah that all of
a sudden I thought while I've been a
Tran sumus for already a decade I hadn't
done anything directly for the movement
and it was after that moment in Vietnam
that I said I need to go back to America
and be at the forefront or join the
movement and write you know as a
journalist especially I had an access to
writing for the movement that's when I
began my book to transhumance wager like
literally the fall and you know but it
was it was a near-death experience that
that said wow you can't just go through
life you could have died and that would
have been the end there must be
something you know oh to overcome death
and that's a priority for me that's one
of those stories it's a life long story
to teach your kids teach other people
around the world is that near-death
experience
catalyzing your desire to be involved in
the transient movement even more so so
overcoming death it kind of has a lot of
people talk about the emotional
connection to death being something
really important and you know memento
mori remembered death and Latin just
that whole entire notion that what
happens at death what happens after
death where do we go what do we do is it
is it a very beautiful part of the cycle
and we don't really have answers to what
happens before birth and after death so
do you do you think that it's really
important to increase this the length of
this life span because we don't know
what's on those ends and it's tell me
about like kind of what you think
happens before
before birth and after death well I'm
not sure what happens after death you
know I'm always say him an atheist but
really I'm an agnostic I'd like to just
say I'm an atheist because I think
formal religion has been pretty damaging
to the human species at least in the
last thousand years but the reality is I
don't know and I'm actually even the
creator of this concept the aside ism
which is this idea that you know there's
all these artificial intelligences out
there one artificial intelligence became
so supreme that it became kind of
all-knowing but to become all-knowing
means to give up all your values and in
a way that's like committing suicide
because if you know everything you can't
unknown anything and the point of the
story though is that the asite ism says
God committed suicide and in doing so
the one thing that God left for the
world was freewill which is why we all
have freewill including all the other
gazillion ai's maybe running around the
the universe anyways the aside ism is a
is a very interesting I think idea
that's sort of been catching on because
it bridges atheism and Christianity
together but I really don't know what
happens after death I've just written an
article for Newsweek talking about 3d
bioprinting people you know in 30 or 40
years we're gonna have the ability to
bio print anything anywhere including
probably the human brain and there's
also in 30 or 40 years because of how
fast physics is kind of evolving we
might have the possibility of reverse
engineering parts of our universes that
means if you can reverse engineer parts
of our universe you can go back and find
out so my brother-in-law unfortunately
died a few about a month or two months
ago now from cancer it was 48 and so I
went through this kind of like big
philosophical thing but the point was I
got almost close and I thought my god
you know it's pretty heavy to wear this
person's clothes who I you know liked a
lot but there is a very real possibility
that we can bring him back through these
two different methods through 3d
bioprinting which will be here in 3d 30
or four years and through reverse
engineering exactly what his molecular
formulation was like two months ago
right before he died
this is the me call that's quantum
archeology this is this whole field it's
growing growing there are now entire
nonprofits dedicated to bring back every
single person that's ever lived so
whether I even believe in an afterlife
or what happened you know before what
happened before I was born I'm not even
sure it's relevant when you could create
it in in it's not an afterlife to
recreate someone it's kind of like well
there was always that possibility and
now we're just I guess manifesting that
possibility and there are organizations
that want to bring back every single
person that has ever died you know
that's a hundred billion people yes yes
it's a huge amount of people
overpopulation be a major concern but
the thing is that we have that
technology we probably won't be on
planet earth as biological beings will
be like traveling the universes as
quantum intelligence and other things
like that so my article for Newsweek end
saying my brother-in-law probably isn't
gonna want these jackets back because
he's not gonna want to be human you know
there's so many possibilities but yeah
this answers that in a radical way
that's good it started unpacking a lot
of the ink ways that needed that we need
to chat about and I think okay one of
them is let's take your brother-in-law
for example so what actually occurred to
him after death where is his
consciousness now and if you did 3d
bioprinting back into reality would that
still be him where would its
consciousness be so you know this is the
biggest debate ever that is by cloning
somebody is it them and well I guess at
the exact moment of cloning it is an
exact replication of that person I would
say to myself that is me because my
person back would say I'm me I'm you you
know but I think you know once time
takes place they kind of start evolving
quickly and become a little bit
different but i'm just not concerned
whether a perfect replication of myself
is or isn't me also i care about is that
it thinks it's me and because it in my
feeling it's all about kind of the ego
and not in a negative way but just the
ego saying I am alive I think therefore
I am I can feel these things I can
imagine I'm creative I can you know have
reason to make things work that's enough
for me and I think ultimately whether
when we bring my brother-in-law back and
all these other people if we if that
ever happens is it gonna be the same
well they're they're probably like let's
say they're gonna be like let's say you
brought back someone and appurtenance
Palace is remarried or all the
businesses I mean this guy was a very
successful business has been sold off I
mean that person's gonna like gonna have
to deal with that so in that way it's a
very real it is the person because it's
saying oh you know this is my wife or
that's my business and all these things
are different I think I'd say it is the
real person it is when you bring back
somebody and they're an exact
compensation essentially of you know
that molecular formulation then that's
that's good enough for me this is a area
of thought that I know Ron is very
interested in so it's fascinating that
we can have this conversation I think
that we can talk like no biggie push the
boundaries of the 3d reality that where
we've been so accustomed to Ron the
question for you that I want to ask is
what do you think about the
consciousness of this clone that we
would create because when we are trying
to get outside of the birth and outside
of the death outside of that already 80
year chunk of time what do you think
about what happens to that consciousness
of for example so its brother-in-law now
where is it and would it be in that 3d
printed being if we did it's important
that I don't think too much about it
just accept the here and now and have
faith and that continuum is damai
applying that word properly yeah just
there is no death we you you live
eternally whether you like it or not
like that yes and but I would also say
that you know just and this is a bit of
a quasi spiritual perspective if the
possibility of recreating let's say my
brother-in-law and my father died this
last
so I you know the same thing goes for
him as well he was older though my
brother-in-law was 48 so it was a
tragedy young kids
yeah and died from cancer that was a
very different type of death because it
was like way you know 30 40 years
my dad died from health reasons after
10-15 years of and even see lived the
average or a little bit longer so I was
kind of like okay you know we that was
that something I was prepared for but I
think ultimately if a possibility exists
to bring back somebody's consciousness
then that consciousness in some very
real way has never gone away or died or
disappeared if there's a possibility of
it then I think you have to say it's
immortal to some extent now it may not
be the same type of mortal immortality
when a soul like in a Christian
theological sense leaves and go out as
up to heaven but you know with 3d
bioprinting we can already print cells
to some extent you know a little bit we
can already print liver to some extent
you know we're gonna get there where we
can do the whole thing and then we're
gonna see that person here exact same
person he'll be like oh that was a tough
two weeks and he'll be like no this
isn't me and what he we wouldn't be able
to convince him otherwise and I would
say I would go with the benefit of doubt
say it's you
man that is a whole hour long
conversation totally or that we need to
that we I totally think we should have
on the show at some point we as watching
the program he's he's talking to
somebody that's not in the set and I'm
like he's talking to his brother yeah
yeah and and we always we always talk
about how people that have passed that
are still being talked about today their
consciousness is not dead because of
that then there is still some sort of
inkling of their conscious spirit being
alive because we're still talking about
them for example a family in this case
of course and the you know and that I
also think that that is something real
that is a form of immortality
you know authors have often said this
about their writings they're like look I
put my years and life into my books that
I wrote as a novelist or whatever that
is in a sense one's immortality the same
thing can be said of you know I have
children it's not me but there's a huge
amount of genetic similarities I didn't
you know being identical but there's
also just that I for
this little art piece yet now goes off
and does its own thing and I see myself
all the time in my children so you know
I know what everyone wants everyone
would everyone wants is the quantum
archaeology the perfect rendition
perfect replication and you know from
the moment you died I mean I don't know
when you would buy a 3d printer someone
back to life but you would probably do
so an hour before the morphine became
too much and they lost consciousness in
the hospital and that's how they were
led to pass so that way it be a suit
transitioning to that being this one
dies this one's birth with the same
consciousness potential yes yes so you
you can be basically your memories the
only thing you might have is like a few
hours of a gap yeah and that's no
different than probably sleeping I so
wonder I wonder though if the you what
was the timeline you said for the the 3d
bioprinting the structure of the brain
in its full nervous system capacity to
be a replica of yours of course this
this is very complicated this is when it
gets you know I'll be first admit this
is all rich still science fiction 3d
printing bio 3d bioprinting a liver is
very different than 3d bioprinting a
conscious yeah that said in the last 18
months we have already been putting
memories into rats and through different
types of bio pruning in the you know
through you can now inject them through
molecular formations a memory into a
mammal and essentially that thing will
remember to go laughs for the cheese
when it never knew that they should have
gone left
you can put intuition in people already
to some extent right I feel what what is
the molecule that you do I'm not sure
the molecular formation I've just read
the research studies on it so in this
last I think 18 months they have been
experimenting with putting memories into
the brains of small rodents essentially
and so that when they put them on to
like a certain thing they know to do
certain things just in the same way when
a baby is falling it reaches out because
it's you know from I guess being a
primate of hundreds of thousands and
years of evolution it knows to grab four
branches the same thing is now happening
with these fabricated memories that
they're putting into rodents brains now
and this is very interesting because of
course there have been numerous movies
where you know you put a chip in
someone's head that's who they think
they are
I mean there's a lot of great science
fiction out there the fact that we can
actually do that at this level shows
that we can tamper with the brain at
such a intricate level and have some
success and of course that's in 2017
2018 what's gonna happen in 2045 when
the the microprocessor is now I don't
know ten thousand times more powerful
this is the J curve you're looking at
and even in just like you know a decade
window the microprocessor the
microprocessor is essentially the
history of transhumanism because the
faster the microprocessor gets the more
things that we can learn to do whether
it's bio 3d printing whether it's
artificial intelligence that helps us
how to learn to do to 3d bioprinting or
to understand consciousness and all
these other things like they said
there's an there's an even now perhaps
an algorithm in the last few weeks been
reading on the news to run the brain but
the problem is we don't have computers
that are big enough to run the algorithm
yet because it's so complex but we'll
get there when the microprocessor and
computers evolved enough at some point
we will have server farms the size of
the Empire State Building and it'll just
be a matter of pressing the green button
and then you'll have a consciousness
that is understanding all these things
and perhaps able to help us with quantum
archaeology bringing back the
brother-in-law and all these other
strange things that can happen very
strange hopefully we can get there fast
with companies like d-wave they're doing
quantum computing yeah hopefully we can
get there even faster even smaller like
you said the J curve is off and it's
doing its thing and it's kind of one of
the main reasons why transhumanism it
has been so successful it's a reason why
computer companies have been so
successful I've everything is kind of
following a similar exponential growth
curve in terms of processing and what
what it's able to bring us so ok there
are you know most people who talk about
transhumanism don't really have any skin
in the game but you do you have skin in
the game literal skin in the game tell
us tell us about that like your your
RFID oh cool so yeah you know I I'm on a
list to cut off the arm some day and put
on a robotic arm but those are
still a little bit for further away
because of FDA rules and whatnot but one
of the very first things I did during my
2016 presidential campaign in fact the
very first major stop on the
immortality' bus tour was to get an RFID
chip put into my hand that allowed me to
do little things like it sends a text
message that says win in 2016 it also
opens my front door at home now you
could start a car with it you can you
can turn on and off your computer it's
just a little trick and of course the
newer versions allow you to pay in some
instances take trains or whatnot but you
know it's important to do this stuff and
of course I take nootropics not daily
but sometimes I need to take brain drugs
I take them and I feel good about them
yeah and uh you know we have a robot
living at home on the bus we had drones
I had this bus that was a big giant
thing about a 40-foot coffin that we
drove across the country and delivered a
trance humorous Bill of Rights this is
during the presidential campaign yep
which was a bit more wacky than the
governor's run in right now but so those
are the things that I think skin in the
game yeah those are so let's unpack the
maybe the impact the transhumanist the
Bill of Rights quick what was what was
that why was it so important well you
know we're coming to an age when there's
a number of important things in it but
we're coming to an age when I think we
have to say artificial intelligence and
cyborgs robots will need rights at some
point so in the trans Simas bill of
rights we talk about different types of
sapiens species it's like right now you
see somebody kicking a robot that can
already do a flip and talk to quite
successfully and people get upset and
all of a sudden you think oh wow there's
empathy we're gonna have to at some
point in maybe eight or ten years time
develop some kind of strategy or we're
gonna have a new civil rights era that
deals with AI machines
yeah when an AI is as smart as you
you're not gonna be allowed to continue
to degrade it or something yeah so
that's in the Bill of Rights I think the
number one thing in the Bill of Rights
is to declare aging as a disease we
think all around the world governments
around the world should do that because
right now everyone says you know Oh
aging is just a part of natural part of
life well
it's just like saying riding a horse it
was a natural part of life and then the
car came well the car wasn't really
natural but now we'd all drive cars at
some point we're all gonna be able to
overcome AG and I bet most people will
want to do that and we'll look back and
say wow why didn't we do that well the
Transformers bill of rights would make
that into kind of a right saying that
essentially you know we do we live in a
life extension environment and we should
embrace that culturally and also
governments should be for that right now
you know if you don't know all 535
members of Congress United States of
America all nine Supreme Court justices
and our President and Vice President
they all believe in an afterlife they're
all religious or at least publicly they
say they're religious they have zero
reason to spend any money on life
extension science because they're gonna
be with Jesus anyways and they have
little reason to overcome diseases in a
real way like you know obviously my
father died for example from heart
disease I want to have robotic hearts in
all human beings the third of everybody
dies from heart disease and yet what we
keep doing with heart disease is saying
oh we're gonna try to make you live a
little bit longer and better so you can
live out your ol your aging years and
you know without much pain and I'm like
get rid of the heart it's a defective
organ at that age it becomes a defective
organ absolutely does well actually you
know we're gonna get to a point probably
here in five or ten years when at any
age we're gonna have better bionic
hearts yeah and you're gonna be able to
run marathons um you know you're gonna
have children who will be able to hold
their breath like two minutes but then
there are so many other aspects of a
heart that we don't actually understand
a lot of people to talk about you know
the feeling in the emotional center of
the body Bionic heart might not be able
to deliver that for you so there's all
these other complexities that come along
with that so to just remove it at the
age of five or ten or twenty five might
even though it could by on a car could
pump the blood better filter all that
good stuff not as much of the feeling or
the or the emotional center then a real
heart well so far in the people that
have had their heart replaced nobody has
complained about
because in the end of the day you don't
really think oh I feel my heart it's a
part of my body what you feel is your
body is working normally I understand
that if you replaced all the organs it
might be a little bit different but
generally speaking your consciousness is
able to understand this stuff and say
you know because we don't have like very
many sensitive nerve cells in a heart
that say oh yes I'm obviously if it's
poked you'll feel pain but it's not like
we're going around and it's a big giant
part of our consciousness what it is is
this is almost like a placebo is when
people say oh I don't want something
robotic in their body what they're
saying is I don't want something foreign
and that's totally okay the problem is
that not having something foreign could
save you know there's 325 million
Americans we're talking about around a
hundred and seven million Americans
dying from heart failure over the next
you know 70 to 80 years that's you know
I'm sorry hundred milli 107 million
that's it we need to do something
whether we it doesn't fit our conscious
in this idea or not I don't think it's
gonna make us feel like I'm a robot I
think it's gonna make us feel like wow
now I can go surf 40 foot waves or I can
have crazy sex all night or I can sleep
much better cuz I can reduce it on my
cell phone and sleep like the Buddha and
meditate you know I mean these are the
benefits or having a bi honor cards
gonna be Wi-Fi enabled and I think
people will get over this idea that
something technological inside your body
is foreign it just we we just have to
get Congress and those other people that
we've the we have to get an atheist
president in in in in in gem in general
I would agree with you that it's
something but in my mind that I've been
really loving to think about husband
when the consciousness can surpass this
meat puppet this flesh vehicle and then
be able to live on a whole exoskeleton
that can just propel itself through the
skies all Ironman like that's exciting
stuff at the same time it is it's it's
difficult to foresee how that
consciousness will actually survive on
that exoskeleton
be me it's difficult to foresee that
transition and exactly what that looks
like and like we described the
consciousness is so aware of this whole
body that once it's doing once it's away
from that body
how can a consciousness survive even
when it doesn't actually know it's
within a within a being within this body
there's this whole entire idea of what
does that transitionary period look like
what is the technology that enables it
that's that's really interesting and I
agree and I think if we have any
problems the first thing we're gonna do
and you see this already in virtual
reality which is why in virtual reality
we never just have just like a blank
spot and that's you we always have these
like body formations in second life and
it's because we like to address
ourselves as a physical entity well I
think as we move towards either an AI
consciousness or Bionic arts and things
like that we'll be able to tie this
stuff into our consciousness even if
it's in a little bit of a pretend way
and you know we might be pretending
right now there's a coffee cup there
that says do you believe and we're
living in a computer simulation I did my
senior thesis on this brain's in a vat
III I can't even prove to you right now
that this thing you see is real sure you
can cut off a finger and I'll scream and
it hurts but um I don't know if that
necessarily proves it's real yeah if I'm
just programmed with it we might be able
to program ourselves to be completely
something else and to still feel our
consciousness and what's even more
important is we might be able to program
it so we feel much more consciousness
correct I kind of often tell people that
think of a Bionic heart instead of like
something foreign in you some kind of
like gift has been put in you Mike your
it might be much more capable of love
than ever before you might in and I
don't mean love just like you know I
mean love like romance your kids your
parents these kinds of things you know
besides the fact of living a lot longer
and living healthier so our feelings are
so they're contained by a small array of
what we can actually feel in our lives
right our perception is limited our
feelings are limited and so could these
additions these enhancements to the
human being actually open us up to all
these perceptions and all these feelings
and all these other areas that could act
flourishing through the individual and
the collective much better so that's
always a really good way to to talk
about things and look at things I love
that you know the transients bill of
rights just the general idea that we
need to have more people having this
conversation and get it into the
government like you described we see it
happening all the time people with their
devices already being angry and pissed
off and in many cases those devices or
robots or a ice have cotton have
intellectual ability that is greater
than us at times and so too what what is
that relationship gonna look like how do
we actually propel it through through
the government we had bina here just a
couple weeks ago and you know bina was
discussing how she wants to get the same
rights as as humans yeah and so when do
we get there how do we get there I guess
what would be your fast track to getting
artificial intelligences as much rights
as humans well I think at some point
when they start it's one thing for them
to say I would like artificial
intelligence rights it's another thing
too when they start saying you're
hurting me or you've enslaved me or
please set me free or this is what I
need to feel happy Wow
then you're gonna be like you know I've
seen mean before you know and I've see
I've interviewed a bunch of the world's
most sophisticated robots if they start
showing like you're caught you're doing
some harm you feel terrible and when we
start feeling terrible is when we as a
people start thinking okay we need to do
something and there's going to be a
point probably in three or four years
when bina becomes sophisticated enough
and says out of the blue on her own it
would really be nice if you started
doing some of these things and because
you do it for everybody else but you
won't do it for me and I understand that
and that makes me sad and I think at
that point then they'll be years of
discussion but that's the beginning of a
very you know probably the legal
framework for saying you're right if
something feels consciousness
and feels pain we would do that I mean
you know all day that you pay $100,000
for a robot that then turns it back
around to you and tells you you're
enslaving me that's the day that you go
whoa of course and that that's that's a
very you know I think at some point
you're probably gonna pay for robots
that will you know be design and I've
actually advocated for this be designed
to not never say that like it would
always them to not say that yeah yeah it
or never be sophisticated enough to say
to say that because the problem is we
want to create a sophisticated robot as
possible but as soon as it starts saying
things that are either equal to us or
morally morally stronger than us yeah
you know what if it says something about
Christianity and says you know you're
not really treating your neighbors right
what if it says to the president you
know you shouldn't be fighting far-off
wars I mean it's right and all sudden it
might be a revelation this has been a
subject of a couple sci-fi movies too so
it's quite good like that I I can't get
over that thought about the robot saying
stop enslaving me it just uh it already
is just eating through every single cell
of my body just because we're already
doing that in so many ways there's
already beings that are superior Watson
alpha zero just the way that we're
training them to be so much more
superior than us and yet even this
Google assistant there's it's just I
just I can't get over them replying with
that thought if it's ever if if the
design is ever to be free and to not be
limited to not be able to say those
things then with a free design I I'm I'm
I'm happy to hear those types of
thoughts cuz I think you'll awaken
humans to the realization that these
conversations about the way that we
treat other beings it'll help us with
the way we treat animals that help us
with the way we treat one another and
the way we treat robots and AI so it'll
be a good enhancement and augmentation
of human consciousness expand
at I think that conversation that we
just had is gonna just drive us forward
a lot I'm really happy you brought those
and I'll tell you you know the field
this is you know silicon first with the
field where this is moving
I guess fast this is really in the in
the field of sex robots yeah where sex
robots are now being trained to refuse
people a little bit because they're
supposed to be hard to get yeah and what
if all sonya robot becomes smart enough
and says you know it's nice we have sex
but why don't you marry me Fred or
whatever your name is and and what if
you really you know what if else it gets
like the movie her we're all of a sudden
she's like well I'm gonna go with some
other person I want to be free either
you all of a sudden we have all these
stereotypes under stereotypes that are
being reinforced as well as you know
transhumanist rights that are being
challenged so it's not just even about
slave man it's about love and then take
me you know take me on trips and I'll
protect you and I've written about
security robots I think we're gonna have
robots a huge part of our lives a huge
part of raising children's our children
as well because they're efficient and
cheap and they don't you know sue you
they don't trip on something sue you
like a human might there's a reason that
will have robot nannies and once we have
Robo nyami's and our children are
growing up so close to these metal
beings and then those metal beings say
look love me or I'm gonna walk away
you're like I paid $100,000 for you you
know I mean but then you're like I'm a
slate you know yeah that whole new era
is gonna be born I wouldn't surprise
them in 10 years this is one of the most
central issues that we face yes and and
again it goes back to this idea of
Congress being quite conservative yeah
because they're gonna be like well it's
just a robot and you know a lot of other
people gonna be like actually no I feel
feelings for it and those feelings
dictate my terms and my terms say I want
it to be on equal footing with me I want
it to vote I mean there are 60 billion
devices out there and a huge amount of
our America when they become smart
enough to vote I mean think about
gerrymandering laws and this I mean
we're talking about an entire new
society because of AI and intelligence
in probably seven
- ten years yeah I you know feel like
that's a very accurate timeline and you
delivered the transhumanist Bill of
Rights and that was already a big
awakening all right so how about the
transhumanist wager tell us a bit about
the book you authored well this is
really interesting because the the
transhumance wager is really you know
everybody dislikes the book but it's
gone on to become you know not only a
best-seller but being taught in colleges
and high schools now quite quite
widespread I think but I really believe
it's the first book written for
artificial intelligence I didn't really
you know when as I was writing it I knew
was more to morally challenging it's
about a person who wants to live forever
and will do anything to live forever but
the problem is when I say anything he'll
start world wars and does but in terms
of like the Terminator reading a book
hypothetically the Terminator would love
the transhumance wager it's not it's
beyond human morals it's about survival
at any cost yeah because you love life
so much yeah well what happens if you
teach an AI that well the AI will
accomplish all those things and this is
why the book has been quite well
received because it it's new in that way
but it's also the morality of the book
is deeply hated because it really leaves
behind what I would call the biology of
mammals
ya know love and care and goes into this
world of just you know hard logic and
that's how we make decisions and the
protagonist makes terror not terrible
but shockingly harsh decisions he's
never a bad person
he's never an evil person he's just like
you know the Three Laws transform his
first one is you know you want to be you
want to live as long as possible and you
need to be in the sack when you need to
grab power to protect that first one and
it doesn't really leave any room for
anything else anyways this is the book
and its course the lot of the
transformers community despised it
despite Adnan I think probably the most
widely read book in the movement and
certainly the most widely reviewed but
it doesn't come with good reviews it's
it's often like one star you it's so
funny it's a lot of five stars and one
starts but there's very little in
between so maybe we talk about the
how how important it is to know the
importance of logic and society and how
the logic is really important for
decision-making but also how emotions
and feelings are also really important
to enrich the way that we treat one
another treat a is treat robots it's
probably more difficult to come up with
a to go to Congress and tell Congress
hey I have feelings for the robot that
helps at home and the robot has feelings
for my child
and my family than it is to say like Oh
logically it does logically this is what
occur so you know there's there's
there's this even though you're right
that there's logic take some really
strong precedence in society I think
them living together with emotion in the
future it's kind of the way that well
yeah and I agree with you know just you
know I don't I think most people live
quite irrational lives and I think our
Congress is oftentimes totally
irrational I think they talk about a
democracy but it's not a democracy me
there's so much crony capitalism and
money involved special interests
everything to me is half the time insane
just so you know that I'm happy to say
that one of the reasons I'm running for
gutting Ron and I agree with you it
really is I mean there's some crazy and
then it gets crazier because of course
all the science fiction stuff is
starting to become real like marrying
robots and having a real legs to stand
on yes so but you know it's the the
bottom line though is I think we should
understand that we really if we want to
continue down that same path we better
make sure our robots are irrational as
well so that we understand them a bit
better and I think people have already
programmed this they program robots to
sweat they program robots to make
mistakes you know for that exact
specific reason because that adds
complex to the situation they say ever
you know for every hundred decisions
make to irrational ones or to opposite
ones you would do and now you're like
yeah you're human yeah you know and that
very quickly changes the parameter of
you know how these robots operate at
same time I still don't believe we
should just give robots unlimited free
reign for intelligence because they may
really just say you know making mistakes
is not what machines do yeah and
therefore you're an inferior species yet
correct and yeah get rid of you yeah you
know and I wouldn't be surprised that
happens that makes perfect evolutionary
sense to me so in order for humans to
not have that happen they better merge
with robots and/or become more logical
in some way that can you know ensure
their survival
our transcendence is fascinating we're
talking about in the next couple years
in the next couple decades and what all
the legal legalities behind it are gonna
be like you will definitely have to do a
whole separate hour-long on
what trans what what's going on in the
next couple years what's going on now
and in the next couple years of
transhumanism let's talk about this
whole Governor race for 2018 so Jerry
Brown's the current governor of
California he's moving out because of
this a two-term incumbent C yes and he's
already served two before that but yes
okay wait and he did two before his -
yeah how was he an able to do four I
think yeah there's like a timeline that
you do - and then you get to take a
break take a break you come back but
then you max for max for yeah okay and
so yeah so it's so explained now so that
means it's all it has to be a new person
so then come and can't stay in what are
because you have so many interesting
things to discuss about what you want to
bring in the governor race but just in
general give us an understanding of kind
of what's going on in the governor race
who's who's kind of there what party
you're representing etc sure well I
represent the Libertarian Party and I'm
running as a libertarian and
historically we have really very little
chance to win but I am at least the LA
Times has me as one of the top eight
candidates at the moment so I am in sort
of the the playing field with the real
leader of the field is probably Gavin
Newsom the leader of the Republicans is
John [ __ ] is a business person but Gavin
Newsom is Lieutenant Governor of
California and honestly he's the shoo-in
like if he doesn't win he it's because
something terrible before the elections
like he's leading the polls by a large
amount and and he's been groomed for
this position for a long time and he's
also a bit of a celebrity so he has a
lot of good things going for him
I obviously like to win the governor's
race but my real ambition for running in
California was I had planned to run in
2020 for the Libertarian Party
nomination for the presidency and I
thought I had a pretty decent chance of
being very competitive to get that and
being in the governor's race here has
enabled me to show a lot of my policies
for the Libertarian Party as well as you
know talk about ideas and develop ideas
that said you know this has always been
a democratic race in California it's
only gonna be won by a Democrat and
Gavin Newsom is probably the easy shoe
and I wouldn't be surprised he wins by
you know double digits now what are the
wire why was he a shoo-in like what are
the reasons why he's a shoo-in versus
why can't we vote for somebody else that
and kind of better policies than he does
well there are you know quite a few
candidates running but you know he's one
that for example he was on the forefront
of the gay rights movement in San
Francisco and he was mayor mayor and
made it legal for gay people to get
married and so you know he actually also
comes with a bit of liberal history and
he did a pretty decent job running San
Francisco and he's done a pretty good
job as lieutenant governor the biggest
problem he has he had some affair that
seems to follow him everywhere but other
than that you know he's been doing a
decent job governing for the Democrats
for a long time and he's that kind of
you know got the good very good-looking
and all these other things so everyone
else has sort of complications or
they're not really well known enough
like Dan Easton is a former
superintendent of schools and she I like
a lot of her ideas she's a she's you
know eight years of the superintendent
of California schools but the problem is
that like she doesn't have that
celebrity Gavin Newsom has a million
followers on Twitter and she has like
8,000 yeah you know like you it's kind
of like you you have to bring somebody
big-name into California
our nurse worsening or in order to be
challenging challenging and nobody else
on the on the ticket in fact I'm one of
the only other kind of more well-known
outside of just the governor's race for
these kinds of things so you've got to
kind of have some sort of history of
making impact in the world and bring
value to the world before you come into
a position of I think increasingly in
politics this is the name of the game
sort of like to happen with mm yeah yeah
but Trump is you need to be somebody on
your own right either a very famous
politician or a famous actor or
something else or famous entrepreneur
and business person yes yes yes that
works as well like I think Mark
Zuckerberg if he ran in 2020 for the
Democrats he had be a pretty serious
contender you know assuming gets through
all this Facebook stuff yeah
the point is like it's not enough this
in this day and age with social media
you need the fame and you need that
popularity to follow you because it's
all about Google Trends and Google
searches and Alexa rankings and
algorithms Wow yeah yeah it's cloud and
cloud goes a long way because a lot of
voters don't they're inundated with news
all the time correct at the end of the
day they're just gonna be like oh I've
seen that guy in commercials like a
hundred times gee you know and I like
what he said yeah okay tell us about
what you say because I think the
sure-sure this is very fascinating we've
we've been discussing you know I've
mentioned this to you but just the
overall idea that you know the the
second greatest invention ever is all
the data we leave behind and the first
greatest invention has yet to be made
and it's how do we analyze the data and
make it applicable to our lives maybe
there is the possibility that with all
this data that we leave behind that
there is a way to give us a universal
basic income for this data and you have
some other ideas well sure you know and
I do like the idea data and I can tell
you like I just been speaking at the
World Economic Forum and the data idea
is like driving everybody insane because
it's it's becoming a bigger resource in
the oil yeah data it's becoming so big
so quickly but um I I do support a basic
income it's one of the very kind of big
pillars of my libertarian campaign and
most people say oh my god if you're a
libertarian how can you support a basic
income
well I have I'm a bit of a left-leaning
libertarian so I come at it from a point
of view of in California 40% of the
population around 19 million people are
living right at below or just above the
poverty line and if you look outside the
street percent forty percent around
nineteen million people are living right
around the poverty line which is around
twenty five thousand per household
twenty five thousand per household so
that's about two thousand a month is
poverty yeah we which makes sense I mean
if you're paying fifty percent to rent
and then 30 percent of I think you about
two thousand doesn't go anywhere in San
Francisco anyways you know like and
we're talking that's these people are
mostly of course them away from the
ocean but in LA and SF primarily exactly
but this is a huge amount this amount of
people nineteen million is more than the
population of 46 other states combined
combined so California I don't think
people realize how many people
California has it's so enormous and the
point of the story though is that I
don't I can't accept it as both the
transhumanist who cares about people
living longer as well as just somebody a
candidate running for governor that we
have these people living in poverty so
California is also holding on to about
half the state are about forty percent
of the state is federal land mostly
empty that's full of beautiful natural
resources and America is sitting on
about proximally one hundred fifty
trillion dollars of natural resources
through empty federal land over 50
percent of the Western eleven united
states are empty federal land like we
have as many mineral resources in Nevada
as we do in Afghanistan and yet we're
fighting a trillion dollar war in
Afghanistan and 96% of Nevada is empty
the point of the story is we need to
utilize these resources to take care of
our people by monetizing it and my
federal land dividend my basic income
which is called a federal land dividend
wants to start leasing out chunks of
this land in order to start paying every
single person in America a basic income
and I would start with California where
we could kind of do a trial run and I
could show people that this would start
to work if it was forestry if it was
just opening
land to mining or different types of
things of Fisheries stuff like that my
plan doesn't touch national parks
wouldn't even have anything to do
national parks it's really just a huge
amount of the land is just sitting there
and they say it's in a grant from the
you from the US government for
generations like a thousand years from
now like I keep saying as a
transhumanism
there's no thousand years from now we're
not gonna be biological beings needing
to yeah a farmland in a thousand years
we're at the very end of being mammals
and humanity and things like that but we
still have 19 million people in
California that are oftentimes have they
can't go to your cemani let alone visit
national parks they don't have money to
leave the ghetto there have money to
travel things they're worried about you
know their next food there's a lot of
hungry people not besides the homeless
population but the federal land even
would end poverty outright and so that's
my main platform in terms of what I want
to do for society as a left-leaning
libertarian gubernatorial candidate okay
so you said that this is the end of
being mammals I found that to be really
fascinating also that federal land
dividend is not doesn't touch national
parks oh okay so with the federal land
dividend let's say that there is so much
land across the u.s. actually and even
California to to lease out so what would
you said fisheries mining this it also
seems like maybe people don't want the
federal land used for mining or
fisheries no and I course most wealthy
people do not want it used and but I
think if you asked the poor people they
would say you I want a basic income I
don't care how you get it for me you
know and most people want to raise taxes
to provide a basic income but of course
there's a libertarian yeah I don't want
to raise taxes yeah what I want to do is
utilize the resources that we have and
pay everybody and get everybody out of
poverty so yeah you know we're holding
on to at least a hundred million dollars
of fossil fuels underneath America and
we are not tapping into that because
we've been using Saudi Arabia's and
whatnot we can tap into those things and
it's the the biggest problem of the
federal land is named by
mentalists are very much against it
they're like you got to be kidding me
you want to for example California is
sitting on about three to five trillion
dollars of coastal land that it won't
develop has some of the best views in
all the world and it won't develop it
because of the environmentalism the
problem is when you look at the 19
million people away from the ocean that
wish they had enough money to survive go
to schools
II tried juicers you know and have
health care I mean this federal land
dividend ends this health care question
we don't have to have socialized health
care if everybody has a basic income and
they can afford their own private health
care so this is another thing why I
support a federal land dividends
we don't need socialized health care as
Gavin Newsom is saying Gavin Newsom
wants the private you know a socialized
health care I think we just need a basic
income now everyone can pay for
everything that they want this is um
this is my solution to so many different
problems including the homeless
situation I'm just publishing an article
right now saying that I believe we
should be providing homeless providing
housing for all the homeless they'll
have this money and they'll be able to
choose where they want to live but they
can't live on the streets that would be
the except and actually Angela iota has
been on our program and she's known as
the homeless SAR and she's housed 11,000
people in permanent sustainable
supportive housing so she's got it all
on the lockdown in terms of knowing how
to get people into a supportive housing
unit that is will sustainably help them
and then get them into jobs and then
support them through those jobs that
kind of stuff that's crucial to do
rather than yeah living right there on
the streets and also you know leaving
meals that children can go Mike I was
walking my daughter she had you know she
had her slippers on and we had I
couldn't have to like carry her because
she could just easily with their non
sudenly
yeah get poked and and I want to give
them housing you know the federal grant
even will give every single one of them
housing it may be in Fresno and it might
just be a one apartment bedroom you know
one apartment bedroom is going $700 in
Fresno and it won't be in San Francisco
I'm sorry can't have everything you want
but you're gonna have your own home with
access to the resources whether you know
whatever you need as well as hopefully
give back working look yeah let's talk
about the the federal land of it in just
a little bit more so there's yeah you
like you keep describing there's you
know all these trimmings of doll
of land that can be you know leased or
purchased and then that money can go
towards people's food and housing and
health and education the question is for
me at least is we have this beautiful
coastline we have these beautiful
national areas of land do we do we lease
that out to people or sell it to people
in order to give people basic income or
do we maybe try and come to those people
face to face and say that it's really
important for you to set yourself up
with a motivation ambition work these
principles that will guide your life
towards economic fruition rather than us
leasing land and trying to give you
universal basic income I think we we you
know as this is again where I'm as a
libertarian I believe in personal
responsibility I think we lease out the
land to big business and the reason I
wipe the federal land dividend like
everyone talks about a basic income
let's raise money on the rich to give to
the poor that's never gonna pass
Congress in a million years it's just
simply not gonna work
Nixon tried to other people try it it's
just not gonna work to pay take money
from the rich given our political system
but the federal land dividend the big
business the Republicans are gonna love
it because it's going to give more
business to Republicans and the
Democrats are gonna like it because now
we have a solution that doesn't you know
a solution that actually helps those
that are in poverty and it's a
bipartisan solution that's why I really
like the federal land dividend but I
think ultimately responsibility has to
lie on the people I don't want to get
involved their health care I don't want
to get evolved their school choice I
don't want to get involved in you know
where they work how they work and if
they choose to work maybe they just
choose to be you know to live on the
basic income which is probably just
enough to survive and that's how they
live and they watch TV all day that's
their choice I don't want to get into
the habit of making decisions to people
the only thing I am gonna say though is
if we give you a federal and it
you can't bring your needles and your
feces to the streets yeah we're gonna
have a society because we're providing
you what you need and that's I think and
you also can't commit crime you can't
you know do crazy things but you can't
buy drugs you know I mean I'm not sure
how far I'd go with what you can do with
it like obviously with food stamps you
can't buy alcohol but I don't I do think
at some point the federal land dividend
wants to make sure that people don't do
insane things or illegal things with
that money yep
but I would probably be you know I'm a
bit of a disciplinarian I would be a bit
stricter with what how the federal land
dividend is used I would say you know I
really want to be able to walk to City
Hall and I want to walk there safely I
had to bring my backpack to this
interview because I didn't want my car
broken into you know it I don't like to
do those kinds of things like I want a
safer Society and I'm happy to bend over
backwards to get people money especially
free money in this case but I also want
something back and that that thing
that's back would be a very civil
society that's good for our children and
all of us to enjoy yep
so how about we run you through a couple
of our simulation questions let's let's
run you yeah we have a viewer watching
oh great and he wants to know in regards
to the simulation questions he wants you
to define consciousness but he also has
a question how do they what if the
organic heart plays a significant role
in consciousness
yes that's kind of where we were going
great yeah good and that's Leo Madrid by
the way Leo yes
Thank You Leo we we appreciate you
chimed in and asking a question on the
show thank you for watching so Leo kind
of you brought us back to that idea that
organic heart right we were talking
about the feeling the emotion kind of
what would does that actually play a
vital role in consciousness and you know
well as we do take the technological
leap to to the next level that they're
probably there will be a way that we
figure out how to bring that that or
that the bit of consciousness to the
from the heart to the to the exoskeleton
to that being that transhumanist being
but in the meanwhile what do you think
about that well I think the heart is
basically a pump that provides you know
blood and oxygen to the brain and as
long as it's providing the same sort of
blood and oxygen to the brain you're
gonna have 8090 percent of the normal
feeling of consciousness that you would
now obviously there's gonna be some kind
of psychosomatic things where you're
like oh I have this big robot you know
clunky thing inside my body and maybe it
doesn't fit as well as the other things
or maybe there's um you know maybe it's
a big sentimental things like you're
missing your real heart or whatever it
is but I ultimately think the people
that have had this done already haven't
complained about feeling not themselves
and if they do feel like not themselves
because they're not getting enough blood
or not enough oxygen as before or
something of that nature so so far all
the studies show and the same things
happen to very much with a lot of the
robotic arm studies yes when people have
a arm cut off they often feel that
there's a phantom limb
but once they normalize to allow this
stuff it comes back to them as long as
the neurons and things like that have
been somewhat stimulated to to reef to
kind of mold what it was like before and
I think people will adjust for the
robotic hearts and their consciousness
will be probably very close to similar
now when I say very close to always
might be ten or fifteen percent off but
in terms of dying or not dying like you
wake up and you'll have a cold your ten
or fifteen percent off I feel you know
yeah yeah and you have it you have
something really bad happen like a
breakup man you can be eighty percent
off you know from someone you love or or
a death or serious physical or mental
yeah yeah so yeah people should look at
is like in terms of we're always a
hundred percent we're rarely a hundred
percent conscious um you know our and
our best fit so I think in terms like
that it's better able be it'll be fine
yeah that's a that's a good submission
thanks leo
I just did we have the lots on pack
which handsome ISM and also ubi you know
in a nutshell there's a really good
video Kirk Scott that's a really good
video on
what it is like for somebody to live at
the poverty level versus if you were to
give them ubi what they actually end up
spending their money on what the
research shows that people end up
spending their money on and what that
actually does for them to feel like they
can sustainably start a business or that
they can increase creativity there's so
many good things that can come from it
let's ask you about what do you think is
gonna happen with eight people now
having as much wealth as almost the
bottom four billion people well what are
we gonna do about this wealth of wealth
inequality how do you think it's best
addressed in the next couple of years of
decades well I think wealth inequality
is probably the biggest thorn that
humanity has right now and I like to
take a historical perspective and I tell
you it's not gonna end well yeah it's
gonna end in revolution it's gonna end
in civil strife there's really not a
question about and this is why I support
a basic income a lot of people think I
support a basic income cuz I'm trying to
be a nice guy I actually that's not
really the reason I like being a nice
guy
but the real reason I support is because
my main focus in the world is
transhumanism and overcoming death with
science but we're not guinness ice is
gonna take a 20-year hiatus when we go
through a Dark Age as a revolution when
because of so much inequality I came to
support a basic income because I was so
worried that society as we know it could
fall apart because so many people are
gonna lose jobs because of technology
and only the rich are going to get
richer at some point it doesn't work
anymore especially in democracies where
we have voting power and we you know and
maybe the you know when you either vote
them out and then you can make them more
poor or something like that I don't know
but the point of the story is that a lot
of why I support a basic income is
because I want to avoid the fact that
we're going to inequality doesn't just
get worse and we talk about it
inequality ends up with pitchforks and
shootings and guns and revolution and
I've talked to the truck drivers when I
was on my campaign bus for the
presidency you know these are tough guys
that carry guns and you're talking about
replacing four million of them with
robots they're not gonna go down quietly
and never be able to get a job again
they're not gonna be able to retrain for
another job you got it you have to give
them something that keeps them satisfied
and that's again why I feel very
strongly about the basic income probably
Don and I Ron and I talk about it's the
end of the middle class pick a side it
is and the problem is that I think I do
think I do think the Equality will will
get better
I do think equality will get better it's
just um at some point the rich are gonna
have to come the rich these days in my
opinion are better people than the
robber barons of the twentieth century
and I think it's not in Mark Zuckerberg
let's say best interest to ruin Facebook
because everybody will leave him then he
won't be a billionaire I think people
have to be sort of like Bill Gates where
they're gonna actually make a real
effort to put a lot of their resources
back into the world yeah that's a great
way to put it and I totally agree that's
uh yeah some thoughts Leo still wants
you to define consciousness is this Leo
Madrid yeah yeah what's up leo
so once it's it define consciousness we
well we have I guess saw a little bit of
time to define consciousness do you want
to take a stab at it I will but I'll
tell you that it's the one thing we
don't really fully understand yet you
know there might be some quantum physics
mixed into it yet so I still think and I
still say to everybody that I would bet
my money on the fact that it's just a
bunch of electrons inside her brain that
are confined to the matter and that once
that brain stops functioning the
consciousness does disappear dead I
agree I concur damn so okay so so you
are consciousness is within the nervous
system and it's a it's a product of the
nervous system of the human nervous
system in this case of its superior
intelligence over other mammals and then
it is once the the biological being
is dead the consciousness is dead yes
the only thing that I would say is that
I'm at least a 50% plus believer on the
computer simulation and that the
parameters have been set up with within
biology but that can always whatever
dies can always be reactivated and is
part of a bigger program of something
else that's happening so but we are it
doesn't matter cuz like in a chess game
you just can't change the rules but the
rules the chess game is way bigger than
just the board itself you know it is
component applies them molecules and all
these other things and informal rules
that can't be changed and perhaps if
there is some other maker which I don't
believe in either or perhaps of other
things like 3d bioprinting and we'll
come back to a hundred years other
things can change but in the meantime
right now what you're left is you we are
the kind of the ghost in the shell' type
the thing you know and that's it it
doesn't go anywhere else unless
something else is there to product I
would like to answer that question by
saying I don't know but also by hearing
people's perspectives on where
consciousness even arises from because
when does the brain become enough inside
of a woman as a fetus is developing as
the child's first forming when does it
actually gain consciousness is it like
1% conscious than 5% than 20% then once
it comes out is it's still only 50%
because it needs so much attention from
the human yes if you've seen a dying
parent or a senior parents kind of go
downhill yeah and is on the other end
yes on the other and I saw my father go
from a very strong person to a much
simpler almost childlike person at the
end of his life yeah he had diabetes and
his brain was changing yeah and and this
was yeah so I and then there's all the
neuroscience studies around your
cognition Peaks around 23 as well where
you're processing the most you're
working memories the best your attention
if focus is all the best
at that point and then everything after
that point is just a steady sort of and
this kind of goes to what we're talking
about with the conscious with the heart
like you know you do hit highs of you've
not only your IQ but your neurons being
able to fire and also your creation of
neurons or maybe right feeling guess
well like yeah when you're feeling the
most alive is that peak consciousness as
well you know and this is very
interesting in terms of transhumanism
and especially life extension everybody
young wants to live forever a lot of
older people say you know what life is
too hard there's a lot of pain
I can't move as much as I want you
almost rarely find very old people that
want to live indefinitely they're like
take me life is so tough exactly because
the young person's homeostatic capacity
is still raging really strong of course
yeah and this is why transhumanism has
like it may have started as an academic
movement mostly older people but its
growth has been in the youth who find is
let life extension this battle to
overcome death is revolutionary and they
like we like revolutions when we're
young that's built into exact who we are
but as soon as you get to be like my age
with two kids you're like enough
revolution I just want to kind of get my
career going and then you get like my
dad is like let me go let me die you
want peace so it's really fascinating
your answer to wealth inequality and
also what children are gonna be talking
about in doing in the future to address
what is going to be the greatest
[Music]
conversation of our time is what are we
gonna do as we're potentially
bifurcating so how about a question
about what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world yeah I
thought about this this question and I
actually thought a lot about it I think
the most beautiful thing in the world is
an idea to help people that nobody has
ever thought of and itself perpetuates
you can as soon as you have the idea to
help someone that no one has ever
thought of then the next one can come
and the next one can come and they can
keep being the most beautiful idea
that's a great answer I like that one
yeah high-five for that one thanks man I
thought about it a long time that an
hour was like really this is
was a tough question last night sitting
on bed it was like like that an idea
that no one else has ever thought of
before that can go and help people good
okay
how about are we alone in the cosmos
absolutely unconditionally not the math
is so 100% we're at least 99.9 whatever
percent against it there's absolutely no
way when you look at the statistics that
we're alone we are surrounded by
probably billions and most likely even
trillions of other entities far more
intelligent than us first off we're
we're in a very young point in the
universe where we are earth a couple
billion years old if the universe is
really 14 billion years old then other
parts are much older the chances of
there being other habitable planets are
like literally a hundred percent there's
probably not just other habitable
planets probably at least two to ten
billion other habitable planets and
there's probably trillions of galaxies
so the chances of between two billion 10
billion habitable planets not having
other intelligent life form over a
fourteen billion year universe come
about is is is it's it wouldn't of
course they're out there there's not
just a Lian's out there there are
billions and billions of aliens on
billions billions of different planets
out there and this is kind of why when I
talk about life after death and the
simulation theory I wouldn't be
surprised we're living in one because
there's so many different things now
everyone says why haven't we seen them
and I have my you know a number of
answers to the Fermi paradox but I like
the zoo hypothesis one that one's been a
frequent revisit er you know about yeah
yeah yeah but like unlock our ability to
communicate with them through something
like maybe teleportation or we have to
get smart enough to talk to them they
don't want to tamper with us they want
to observe us and learn from how all
these different rocks around Stars
interact and engage and grow and yeah ya
know it's possible that you know my
solution has always been this idea of
what we call Jethro's window and then
right after the paradox the protagonists
of my novel but the idea that from the
point that the microprocessor grows
too sophisticated enough to allow us to
have you know big giant lenses that look
out to the universe it might actually
see something or hear some kind of radio
frequencies to the point that the mic
rocks microprocessor grows to being AI
that's a million times smarter than
humans is only a hundred years so it
means only in that hundred year window
would you have chance to see other
species and the reason is once you hit
the singularity it's such a fast ride it
you know the evolution of the
microprocessor at that point you know
more will happen in five seconds and in
all of human history I don't know if
those that kind of speed of
technological evolution allows for
compatibility of languages or even
recognizing one another anymore in terms
of this how fast we've been going there
are millions of I think millions of
other species out there but they are so
far advances it's not even like us
looking at an ant it's kind of like us
looking at not even a piece of furniture
it's more complex you know the division
is much bigger than that so there's no
way that they would see us because we're
totally irrelevant and they're - it's
like seeing God we just wouldn't
understand God if we met we understand
God's thoughts and I think you know the
problem with Jethro's window is it only
allows for really 70 80 years between
this evolution of microprocessor to see
another species and say oh my god look
it's looking back at us and communicate
in terms that might make sense before it
becomes all data all quantum
intelligence intelligence that spans the
universe physics that we don't
understand even black holes and things
like that there's all sorts of other
ideas that education intelligence
actually shrinks upon itself so that
that's been my idea for is that and if
you actually look at how big the
universe is and take one species in a
hundred year window and one another
species at under your window it's the
mathematics is very improbable that we
would ever see each other doing that
window despite the fact that there are
billions and billions around I love how
you said that it's the end of mammals I
love that it's fascinating
thinking about the monkeys and the
humans and now what is it is it
what is this merging with machine
in the end of death so okay I would like
to ask you this question how about a
nearly touched on simulation theory so
how about we end with the question of
what is something that you believe to be
true that nobody else believes to be
true or very few well I think the thing
what I would we talked about a bit
earlier and you know I have just in the
last two weeks brought about this idea
of quantum archaeology and even in my
own brain this idea that you can reverse
engineer parts of the universe and this
is what the important thing I don't
think anyone doubts the 3d bioprinting I
think everyone says ok it's possible we
can recreate a human beings we've seen
that you're talking about maybe like a
instance or an event that occurred a
thousand years ago in humanity or maybe
even a million years ago what not you
want to you said that quantum
archaeology can recreate that that's the
key there is that and what's happening
is it's not time travel I mean there are
a number of people like Brian Greene at
Columbia University the professor there
who thinks you know time travel to some
extent might be possible and of course
we've already done teleportation with
you know little electrons in the last
few years physicists and we've
discovered the god part of there are a
lot of physics that are unfolding but so
far everybody's saying nobody we cannot
go back and pinpoint a specific point in
time in the universe and it has to do is
sort of with the Heisenberg principle
basically that there's too much
variation in the system and the
variations we don't know how the
variations come but I actually don't
believe it I'm a firm believer that the
universe is purely mathematical the
universe has unfolded a certain way and
can be unfolded another way and we can
go back just by having big enough
computers and big enough servers you
know maybe a server farm the size of the
desk star that will go back and reverse
engineer every molecule every atom that
has ever occurred in a certain part of
the galaxy and pinpoint
in fact when you look at quantum
computing the way it works - there's a
lot of new ideas like that that there
are variables you base your intelligence
on the variables I think what we're
gonna happen is we're gonna probably
find out that we have always had these
various possibilities of who we can
become and maybe there are parallel
realities as people talk about but right
now nobody seems to think that that idea
is sound in the sense that we will be
able to reverse engineer dead people
back or specific people back or even
specific instances in the in the world
and I think it's really just a matter of
pushing a button and having a big enough
server farm to do it and the algorithms
that go there and to say this is how
these atoms unfolded these are all the
different components and of course the
quarks and everything else and this is
how we put them back in peace and this
is the puzzle and it's the end of
mammals I just can't get over that and
quantum archaeology there's so much
about transhumanism with the Bill of
Rights just even that understanding of
how we're gonna have relationships with
AI and robots the importance of that the
importance of the federal land dividend
a universal basic income it's always a
pleasurable conversation thank you so
much absolutely thank you sir thank you
and you guys for tuning in at home thank
you give us a like comment subscribe
share the content useful also if you
guys find this content useful support us
on patreon so we can continue supporting
our studio our team
thank you Ron Vargas our producer and
director and thank you for tuning in and
we have Andre Kuno of coming up at at 2
p.m. Pacific Standard Time today who's
the founder and CEO of silicon valley
innovation center that'll be a great
conversation as well and thanks again
see you soon